killed by four bullets to the head and
one in his back
look man slim was found dead in his car
in southern lebanon
early on thursday he was a longtime
activist and fierce critic
of hezbollah there has been no claim of
responsibility but his family
has reached its verdict
in this country you are not allowed to
have a voice against the ruling party
they are strong and they won more than a
year ago slim asked for protection
against the iran-backed armed group
which controls political power in the
country
depression in lebanon is going bigger
and bigger the freedom of expression is
vanishing in lebanon there's nothing to
say about democracy in lebanon
this this assassination
tells a lot that we are going into the
era of assassination
for many slim's killing brought back
memories of the post-2005 period
when former prime minister rafiq hariri
and other politicians opposed to syria
and its ally hezbollah
were assassinated the group which has an
armed wing
has denied any role in those killings
and its supporters have come
to its defense
against hezbollah syria and iran but it
doesn't mean fingers should be pointed
at them
there could be someone trying to pin it
on them
for many the killing was a message this
is going to
scare anybody who is going to
criticize or thinks about criticizing
hezbollah in particular
because of who luckman was female
from the same sect as hezbollah shia
islam
he lived in the group's stronghold and
was killed in the group's heartland
for more than a year anti-establishment
protesters have been demonstrating to
bring about a change in
leadership and for the first time those
protests spread
into strongholds of the mainly sectarian
political parties
including hezbollah which was accused of
protecting the system
many blamed for running the economy into
the ground
protesters were attacked by hezbollah
and amma supporters
and journalists have been harassed i'm
a journalist from the shayed sect and
whenever i express my thoughts against
the politics
of the sect and specifically hezbollah i
am labelled as a traitor
authorities are promising an
investigation but his family like many
others say
there's no need for one in a country
where there's rarely been
accountability senator al jazeera beirut